c'est la journée les enfants les cherry
et donc on a on a on a fait appel
en fait aux mini mini chroniqueur nous
avons avec nos mini mathieu
applaudissements pour lui
tu t'appelles bonjour bonjour là bonjour
oui tu t'appelles matthieu delormeau
d'accord très bien ça va tu as fait quoi
hier soir ça rien fait car était content
d'être ici
oui et non c'est qui ton chroniqueurs
préférés à part toi jean luc jean luc
lemoine tamia l'on est loin de pouvoir
dans un instant ça serait bien que tu as
un scoop médiathèque quelque chose
aujourd'hui
oui vas-y à quoi bon soir tu te trouves
bon comme mathieu capsule avec à
comment ça va capucines tiens ça va bien
ma chérie tu es en forme avec le fils de
qui en ce moment il ya mini agathe qui
est avec le mieux adapté
[Musique]
et la linea gâteau fois les fameuses
comment certains agathe
oui ça va tu es content d'être là oui
pas fiancés temps quelle classe non sans
quelques classes pdc pbd cp3 ipd des
bébés dans mes temps quelle classe
vraiment c'est pas seulement passer la
sepnb et au savon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
munich a pu elle a tous nos calculs si
dallas
on a lyon le midi jean michel maire
on voit ça va mais les gens me bien
j'avais hâte à une meuf et non nantes a
pas de meuf
non tu as quel âge non on may 12 ans 11
11 ans tu m'as dit douce tout à l'heure
tu es aussi mito de jean-michel d'accord
en une minute ma famille tall est
d'accord me thierry moreau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va tirer oui comme en tant que classe
toi un cd v bébé comme d'habitude et
hiroto city est ce que tu as une blague
eh oui vas-y au fond de moi ça dans mes
14 juillet le fonds de brosses à dents
le 14 juillet chez ba ba adjoint feu
dentifrice on a avec nous me gilles
verdez applaudissements pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça a bien très bien
alors tu es content d'être là oui tu as
quel âge toi fais pas tu es tout calme
toi mon chéri un oui mais non sans
quelques as fait p c'est que tu
travailles bien cpb fait baisser cp
c'est quoi ouais mais agathe et au
agathe agace mimiague hat yai acceptant
ses pattes en cpcb figo lui lancer pc à
seppi
[Applaudissements]
tu connais gilles verdez oui comment il
est en fait je ne connais pas mme
isabelle mans
comment ça va remuer isabelle ça va très
bien vous avez quel âge 15 ans quinze
ans ça va vous êtes hors de classe en
troisième troisième c'est votre vrai
coiffure tout ça non là d'accord en tout
cas ça vous va très bien oui disent ils
s'appellent morini-bosc un petit peu mon
ami qui est avec nous écrire est
imminent
comment ça va miner nos biens est
content d'être là oui ça va tu aimes
bien la télé ouais tu regardes quoi la
télé mais dessin animé ouais t'as quel
âge
c'est un mini jean luc est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens bien trop bas toi là tu
t'aperçois mini jeanjean régler
seulement ça va bien tu es très élégant
merci c'est très beau si vraiment tu as
quel âge 12 ans 12 ans top des classes
qui 5e 5e à 3 était encore en sixième
savas était content tu connais jean luc
lemoine jean tu connais pas non tu va le
découvrir
d'accord ne l'a jamais vu si tu as deux
amis créant oui
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu veux dire
au tir et franchement il est validé
comment tu t'appelles ça elle enfin
certains cas la saison d'avant il est
pas bon raphaël agathe agathe tu te
calmes il est pas beau raphaël il est
beau mais c'est 6 d'accord très bien
d'accord dans ce cas mais que les
saucisses halal et chérie d'accord les
merguez l'accord les saucisses non au
coeur de l'été